uh but first i want you to meet morgan
harper nichols everybody
she is an amazing poet look at that hat
and that little okay she looks so cute
in that picture too
she's an amazing poet a musician um an
artist whose
social media presence has earned the
devotion of millions including
celebrities like reese witherspoon and
jennifer garner
earlier this year morgan announced she
was autistic and that sparked a
conversation on diagnosing
autism in adults you don't hear that you
know as much
and so she's also out with a new book
called how far you have come
let's get her in here what's up morgan
harper nichols how you doing
hello hello thank you for having me i'm
doing well
doing well oh my god you look great i
love the like handkerchief here you're
so cute yes it's awesome so you're a
very successful artist but until this
diagnosis you really struggled right
yes so i grew up struggling with a lot
of
um sensory issues but i didn't know
that's what they were i would just feel
overwhelmed in settings with
loud music or bright lights and i never
knew why and then
i also struggled a lot with making
friends and in
social situations with like even
listening and understanding
tone of voice but i didn't know what any
of this
was and i spent my whole childhood
up until recently not knowing so yeah
it's a bit of how
how that came about i can only imagine
how that
would have you know really crippled you
socially you know growing up and not
knowing how to
you know having any tools i guess to get
through that
those emotions and that those hardships
so is this true though that
a tick tock video led to your diagnosis
yes it was i was on tick tock and for
some reason the algorithm decided to
show me stories like back to back
stories of
women who had been diagnosed as adults i
was like wait a minute i don't know
anything about
this but they sound it sounds like
they're describing my whole life
so that is what gave me the courage to
get on google and find a specialist in
my area and
thankfully i was able to find someone so
yeah that's what led me to be
able to get diagnosed wow a tick tock
who would have thought that's amazing
um so well you have a new book um and
first i have to show people
how beautiful it is it is just such a
beautiful book
i mean the art in it like it's so pretty
um so can you tell us about this like
what made you want to do this book
yeah so i am a visual artist and a poet
and especially over this past year like
many people
i haven't been able to do a lot of
things that i love to do i love to go
places and see new things so art for me
has been a way of really just expressing
gratitude for
what has been beautiful about my story
what i have how i have learned how i
have grown
and i just think that we all need these
moments
right now more than ever of just having
gratitude for
how far we've come so i hope that the
poetry and art in this book can
help people reflect on that yeah i love
the message too because a lot of people
always say how far we need to go
um and i actually my therapist told me
this recently tmi
um but it's like i always focus on oh
god i still have to do this i have to do
this i really
and she's like why don't we look at like
where you've come from like you know
like from this point to this point like
and it's an amazing thing
um but i think a lot of us some of us
might be perfectionists so
um but how far you have come by morgan
harper nichols y'all it's out right now
if you can't get yourself a physical
copy it is beautiful um thank you so
much morgan for sharing your story with
everybody
oh well thank you for having me thank
you thank you
absolutely absolutely yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever